well here we are what is this what are
we about to do it whatever jumping into
it we're jumping into my release of my
sneaker foot action the line is we are
here with Gary Vee in his offices thank
you so much for taking the time to sit
down and chat with us today thanks for
having me yeah absolutely
what is it about k-swiss that you
decided they or the one I didn't they
came to me what a lot of people come to
me and I say no a lot because this
scares me this moment because you got to
be able to answer to them Yeah right
wearing them on the first day of fifth
or sixth grade I'm still trying to
remember ask my mom but we never took
pictures as Russian immigrants so I
don't really remember so the fact that I
warm the fact that you know I grew up in
the 80s when ice tea or you know or Dre
or other people actually wore them so
and this entire thing the whole thing
that I'm up to is to build an empire of
marketing and communication to buy
nostalgic brands and flip them so for me
this was something I was passionate
about I felt like I could tell the story
because I've rocked them in the past and
it's like nostalgic it's not adidas or
Under Armour or Nike which is even more
interesting to me because I want them
there you know waking up this morning
last night the site's crashing over and
over and over you know whether it wins
or loses it in the macro in the micro
and you know looking at Twitter this
morning and people saying ridiculous
things like what what easy you know what
Connie did for Adidas Gary's doing for
k-swiss that's ludicrous I'm not going
to be able to pull that off I'm not on
that level but even a little micro
version is executing my thesis which is
giving me confidence and cleaning for my
long-term vision that's why the fact
that I me me me at 17 would be in line
right now at Foot action like a bunch of
people are to get this sneaker not cuz I
love Gary Vee but because I saw the
opportunity to make a hundred dollars on
a flip that is a heat that is a big deal
for me and this whole thing I walked in
the complex conned in two seconds I
looked at Tyler like some baseball card
show
yeah I did not feel that in 20 years
right yeah I mean there's so there's
such a there's such a parallel between
what you did with wine and what kids are
doing the she's a hundred percent I mean
they flip shoes and then they build
businesses on top of a hundred percent
the same I pretty much know that ten of
my business partners where I'll be an
invest my deepest business partner I'll
be an investor there'll be a partner or
equity older and something I'm doing
literally right now our sixteen year
olds flipping supreme backpacks one
hundred percent yeah because that's why
I gravitate towards absolutely not
Harvard you know CFO's it's a way of
seeing it's a wave seeing yeah that's a
great way to say it I think we have to
go to your event okay
[Music]
put in those three extra hours you know
put in all the extra that you can but
then also take care of yourself yes
where where do we take care of ourselves
and how do we take care of ourselves in
a way that doesn't undercut the work I
think you know this is where
self-awareness is everything yeah you
know like not everybody wants to make a
million dollars here not everybody wants
cameras on them all the time I think
that's a very personal question you know
I would say that for me I don't make
decisions or live my life on anybody
else's wants or needs I do that my mind
which means I work a lot and I do all
that stuff I don't think I'm where
anybody else is in a position to give
that device even to people I know like a
Justin let alone all the people watching
right now here's what I would say
there's a lot of people I know who make
$200,000 a year in their business and
then go to 275 and at 200 they were the
happiest ever right and a 275 the
business got bigger in a way that [ __ ]
them up
and so for $75,000 offer to others
that's right yeah or the reverse there's
a lot of people watching right now
making eighty-seven thousand dollars a
year hating life but could make seventy
seven thousand a year loving life and
just need to live in a one-bedroom or
rent a studio instead of a what like
there's so many ways to do it are you
just [ __ ] fired up when you wake up
and if you're not back and so to me
there's a lot of people who want a lot
more and don't want to spend it on
Supremes or Nikes or you know adidas and
just want you know whatever it may be
it's not about buying a BMW because
they're insecure I mean I think sneakers
hide insecurity yeah I mean like I don't
know anybody who's a steer collector who
wasn't when they were growing up and
wasn't like picked on like it's oh yeah
compensation the real ones the real I
mean now it's now you're cool right now
it's cool that's why because it's horse
it's always the same
where you can buy status what can
literally put down $400 and everybody
thinks let me tell you another place New
York City nightlife sure you got yeah
everything listen it's all economics
it's always bad well here we are what is
this to come from nothing you know this
is you're not scared appreciate he
bribed a man first you gotta build an
audience and the way you do that is by
putting out content and engaging with
people going into people's comments like
pick something you're past your app put
out content about it and become part of
the community close your eyes for five
years and then wake up at 26 and start
thinking about making money that's hard
advice but that's the real [ __ ] answer
go to Instagram search the companies and
people that you want to get to direct
message them and tell them you'll work
for free and ask 200 people and somebody
will say yes you crying baby bro I'm
living in my storage shed right now just
just pick it up that's its expectation
game right now that is the sheeting here
my love I love it when it meets a good
morning don't matter he's doing because
of you thank you so much how do you man
thank you so much
you never seen my sneakers and the
Stuart ridiculous
I fell somebody had to swim and jump
into the pool you just keep [ __ ]
encouraging them until they go that's
what my content is I just need you to
[ __ ] do something that doesn't feel
comfortable yeah I know the biggest
thing right now in them and that's young
the biggest vulnerability you've got
left it's thinking it's not young I know
that's the only thing just promise me
that it's the biggest thing I feel from
you you know what I mean yeah just
[ __ ] I have that patience you'll win
yeah hardcore yeah
like everyday hustling yeah but macro
patience 100% I'm 11 years old
it's a long [ __ ] game yeah it is in a
video I know if you get and when you
give without expectation yeah like I
don't expect anybody to be here right I
mean it I mean it like if nobody showed
up then that's just what it was right
like I didn't give enough all right that
was the game you know a nice movie for
that not that it was like 100 percent
man you get to that place and the [ __ ]
gets much more fun then you're fully
bought and then you got nothing to lose
it's always the human part that is the
variable advantage because the
technology always gets commoditized
thank you you're welcome so cute he's
out like a light
these be my party all the time very well
thank you literally waited an entire
years achieved eclis planning this
moment now the beta in my definition of
motivation is underrated by you people
who never made a manipulator find a
generation who generated this idea I
hated of going to college my only option
after graduation well look at my graph I
got bars but can't rap I did the math he
was calculated I'm better than ever with
every single better vibe I know the
Michael's ticket the never was never
properly medicated
you can't debate it to music I'm making
has elevated like the pills I've been
paying since I graduated from the sofa
readin outdated education isn't it
amazing how my educated myself to make
me feel the want to possibly change it
seven years I waited and then they're
waitin on tables not able to pay the
payments you're passing on the pavement
now follow the pavement I'm a patient
but lose I'm a patient I'm not
complacent living in my parents basement
gratitude gratitude baby like what's the
alternative right you're younger than
you think you breathe in there Justin if
you're [ __ ] fifty-six you're [ __ ]
young another 40 [ __ ] years what are
you doing here this idea that I'm 44 to
100 so every year I go please wake up
this is not just for these little kids
if you're 56 you got 40 years to grind
thank you thanks a lot thank you take it
they will see thank you repetition
repetition like you know how you kind of
started thinking a little bit
differently just by watching my stuff
well I'm in my [ __ ] head 24/7 so like
if you guys are slightly moving because
you're hearing [ __ ] imagine what's
happening with me vaynernation
stand up stand up no excuses Chardin
yeah yeah thank you thank you appreciate
it yes
vlog when I put up the five don't shake
my [ __ ] hand
that can go work for somebody that you
want to be as close to the center of the
Sun and [ __ ] work at McDonald's at
night I don't give a [ __ ]
go humble as [ __ ] live it only live with
30 whatever that's it man so that's a
man you [ __ ] know clearly this one
now now if you've got that's the hard
part
now do the easy part make a list of 400
producers that you want to [ __ ] with DM
them be like I'll work for [ __ ] free
and grind it out one I was gonna say yes
losing is better than winning
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious and the
second we figure it out and you'll start
winning yes thank you
the only thing you're scared of his
other people's opinion fat men thank you
brother thank you bro
that means a lot to me the last
Telegraph here was this house my first
[ __ ] passing can call me I gotta live
in Colombia I'm working on parts my job
for now yeah looking for eight hours
shoot yeah she's grind grind grind
invest in Colombia a double payment over
here $3,000 $3,000 I could buy two
[ __ ]
that's right straight off the punch de
menthe remover like a year and a half
thank you but I just want you to know I
know I'm gonna die and I'm doing
literally everything I kind of make that
mean
that's amazing but you don't you'll see
happy bird
[Music]
thank you
I see we got I know what they did
[ __ ] get out of here are you good I'm
always good that's great it's your
birthday today happy birthday sir thank
you brother
I would like to ask him a wrapper your
top five rappers of all time biggie yeah
Weezy Bone Thugs don't sleep on
Cleveland then it gets a little Paris
one for me right and too short
hey guys see you later
totally [ __ ] you want to talk about a
real full circle moment in my life
seeing my sneakers being sold secondary
on eBay right now on a flip is about as
[ __ ] is AJ around he left right
that's a good indication of good
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this episode 272 on the askgaryvee show
actually that little fool in there is
exactly how I dreamt it up t-pain is in
the house let's hear it up for him
[Applause]
it was forth basically just it was like
yeah
and everybody else was in a coma
vaynernation on Facebook put in your
phone number you get an opportunity to
now call and ask some questions of a
hip-hop pioneer in a lot of ways in my
opinion and we'll get into that in
minute t-pain for the for the seventy
people who are watching right now that
don't know who you are
give me a little bit your origin story
you know Florida came up pretty much I'm
all doing my thing and I got noticed by
Akon it counts on me what year was that
this was 2005 okay pick on me 2005 in
the same year he took me to John records
every time entire records
what job Riggins is now RCA Records it's
a lot happening between them obviously I
skip a bunch but you know it's a really
good way to put it do you like be in a
studio or do you like a before more oh
man that's hard is it a 50/50 it's a
fear the fear of the day for me because
if I'm in the studio with somebody it's
basically me performing for them right
cuz right now this many people in the
same way it does for me I can see it in
you if there was two people in here
you'd be at certain level if there's at
but do you get compound ly higher like I
only need one but if there is four I get
a little crazier this has me going a
little bit you give me 40,000 and I get
[ __ ] out of my mind
I see so when do you go from shut down
to on 749 if I'm performing on stage if
it's a hundred people in there I'm
you're good oh you don't give me 73,000
so when does the wendy turn on a
thousand four thousand nineteen thousand
300 300 300 so if we throw a show with
299 of my fans in the show shutdown 301
crunk
[Laughter]
let's get a call in guys t-pain's in the
building Facebook put your numbers and
he's gonna get you going
we are unlocking secrets the magic
number for t-pain is three hundred three
hundred is when he turns it pain thank
you so much for the fun thanks for
sharing the struggle which i think well
if it helped one person in this hour
then we won here and I wish you nothing
but the best
good helping on that okay actually be
not steal something see you on this
episode t-pain stops by when I was
listening to severe the book my
investments my career is win-win planet
of the apps if it works right I'm a
household name if it doesn't work when
Apple figures out its [ __ ] I will always
say that it was on Apple's first
original show it was win-win this
sneaker was win-win if it rocked like it
looks like it's about to well [ __ ] I'm
the first entrepreneur to have a sneaker
that matters in culture other
entrepreneurs are gonna get sneakers and
it's a legacy that could get really
interesting especially if you think
about Footwear in corporate environments
you start thinking about four seven nine
years ago if it lost it was such
ridiculous ammo for my best friends to
make fun of me that I thought I could
actually pull off a sneaker and what the
[ __ ] were you thinking so I'm a big
win-win guy I it's why I tend to be
happy I don't do things that have
disproportionate downside I also don't
do a lot of things that have
disproportionate upside which is why I'm
a tortoise even though I wear a Harris
costume my energy seems short-term my
strategy and execution is about as
long-term as that it gets out there and
and I like that and so you know look I
was a guy who got into e-commerce in
1996 Gary thanks so much man I really
appreciate you coming on you guys are
awesome to work with thank you thank you
thank you thank you bye guys I love you
see it see it
[Music]